At the beginning of this course we enumerated seven major principles of
knowledge based AI agents that we'll cover in CS 7637.
Now let's wrap up this course by revisiting each of the seven principles.
Here is the first one. Knowledge based AI agents represent in
organize knowledge into knowledge structures to guide and
support reasoning. So the basic paradigm here is represent and reason.
Represent and reason. If you want to reason about the world,
you'd have to represent knowledge about the world in some way. You not only want
to represent knowledge to support reasoning, you also want to organize this
knowledge into knowledge structures to guide, to focus the reasoning.
Let us look at a few examples that we covered in this course about dispensing.
Semantic networks not only allow us to represent knowledge about the world,
they also allows us to organize that knowledge in the form of a network. We use
semantic networks to address the problem of the guards and prisoners dilemma.
The advantage of the semantic network was that they expose the constraints of
this problems so clearly, so that we can in fact reason about it. And notice
that the organization helps us focus the reasoning. Because of the organization,
there's so many other choices we don't have even have to reason about them.
Frames were on to the knowledge structure that organize knowledge, and
guided and supported reasoning. Given frames for things like earthquakes,
we could reason about sentences like, a serious earthquake killed 25 people in
a particular country. We'll also use frames to support common sense reasoning.
Here, Ashok is moving his body part to a sitting position. Here,
Ashok is moving himself into a sitting position. Here, Andrew sees Ashok.
Now Andrew moves to the same place as Ashok, and Andrew then moves in
menu to Ashok. This is about a story about visiting a restaurant. Once again,
there are knowledge structures here. These knowledge structures are not
only representing knowledge, they are organizing knowledge into a sequence of
actions. These knowledge structures help generate expectations. So
we know what Ashok expects to happen next in any of these situations.
We also know how Ashok can detect surprises. When the non-obvious thing happens,
Ashok knows that it has warranted the expectations of the scripts, and
can do something about it. This is how the script support in guided reasoning.
We also saw this principle in action, when we were talking what explanation
based learning. In order to show that an instance was an example of a particular
concept, cup, we constructed complex explanations. In this case,
we were constructing the complex knowledge structure on the fly out of smaller
knowledge structures. The smallest knowledge structures came out of precedents,
or examples we had already known.
Then we composed the knowledge of these various knowledge structures, into
a complex explanation to doable reasoning, to guide and support their reasoning.
You've seen this principle in action in several other places in this course.
This is one of the fundamental principles. Represent, organize, reason.